- So you do Meryl Streep
impersonations, correct?
Um, so I was thinking in
prep for when pigs fly
and she actually comes on my show
could you show me the impression?
Could you show us?
- Yeah!
Close your eyes, just picture her.
She's here.
- Yeah, she's here.
- Oh, wooh.
(laughing)
Oh, Kelly.
You don't want me on your show, nope.
Oh, I couldn't, (exhales loudly) come on.
(audience applauding)
- That's unbelievable.
- And also, I've heard you before,
I was crying I was laughing so hard,
because every picture I
do see of Meryl Streep
she has the most bad ass glasses on,
they're like, they've
gotta be like $1,000,
they're so cute.
- Yeah, and they're so like
- Designer
- on the very tip of her nose too.
- But with the glasses, it was funny.
You are so awesome, I love
you, you are so, so funny.
So we'll put this on our
Meryl Insta page, people.
You're welcome.